let's talk about doom doom doom doom is
actually I have no right to status you
what you are in the process of reviewing
the game there's a review in progress up
on gamespot 30 will be out later today
it's that we are putting the finishing
touches on all the components that
comprise a games fire can you tell us a
score right now I would you fire me no I
think I mean I think you could probably
tell where were you landing Europe you
like it I'm very positive on the game ok
ya know ray yeah it uh I didn't know how
I felt about doom going into it the e3
presentation that focused so much on
Laurie kills to me was a huge red flag
and so going into this review I that was
sort of the biggest question I needed
answered and it almost immediately I
realized that like no these are fine and
everything around it is way more awesome
than I expected because I thought maybe
the focus was in the wrong place right
but it's not and it's doom is is just a
crazy over-the-top just overwhelming
think experience like it's nuts
everything's on fire everything is
screaming everything is exploding
there's blood everywhere and that's and
that sounds like maybe a really cheap
way to make a game exciting but like the
way that it's paste and delivered to you
is just so well and with such an
attitude and unapologetic attitude about
what it is and where it comes from yeah
and I I was just super happy to realize
that this I remember playing doom is a
kid I feel the same way today I did back
then is not bizarre and you're not the
only person that said that I completely
agree I know Brad a giant bomb had the
same feelings been same for you as well
yeah I mean for me I mean it its excess
is beautiful like everything from
everything p says so the metal guitar
salmon is that we've said this a lot but
it's the most metal game there's Evan it
really makes you want to raise devil
horns I'm just gonna bang your head
but but it there's also like a beauty
despite all this access it's also got
this beautiful simplicity to it which
really encapsulate what it is that made
you fall in love with doom in the first
place and we were talking about this the
other day you know dhoom3 I like doing
through a great deal but never felt like
doom to me yeah yeah it was almost like
a survival horror game right yeah this
perfectly translates what it was or what
my memories and feelings are from
playing those many many hours of doom
and doom 22 to the 21st century you know
it totally captures quite a night it's
almost reductive I think to say old
school or alright fashioned because I i
think that would imply it some kind of
retro experience and it doesn't feel
like a retro experience it it does
encapsulate what it those feelings you
have from playing classic doom but it
doesn't do it in a way that feels
nostalgic or retro yeah it does it in a
in a very sort of modern package yeah
it's got it looks great it sounds
incredible and it has a lot of things
peppered into it little systems right
that are like modern touches things that
we find in modern games that weren't
present in doom that I think make it an
experience that we can look not not just
refer to as retro like it feels modern
but it delivers that same thing that
made that experience back bends so great
which really kicked off a genre you know
I mean shooters weren't really that big
of a thing before doom yeah I mean we
talked about Wolfenstein as obviously
one of the first ones not be first but
but doom was the one that like really
just went oh I caught on yeah people
took stood up and listened that's what's
weird about doom is that if you were to
ask me like two weeks ago what was a
doom game and what I would want in a
dune game I would like talk about stuff
like I don't know atmosphere and like
interesting enemies and interesting
weapons which were kind of all things
that were covered in dhoom 3 much for
muchness and but the weird thing about
this doom is that i was playing this and
I was realizing the things about the
original games that I actually did like
that were in this that I totally
forgotten about things like like the
effect of wandering around and being
lost and looking at that weird map and
trying to find where the secrets are
which is like how they made that phone a
twenty sixteen games like beyond me and
like even looking for a yellow keys and
red keys and I mean that became a joke
about
bad level design for years and years
about how to artificially yeah they and
they put it out there and they do and
they do it but they don't joy it never
feels boring to me the only stuff that
didn't work for me is there's obviously
one of the big things they introduced
here is verticality yeah it's a lot of
mantling and jumping up ledges and there
are some sections which sort of resort
to sudo platforming stun where you have
to sort of negotiate your way up a
little maze of of shelves yeah and it
that stuff didn't doesn't quite work I
mean I think the mantling super fun when
you're doing it in combat because the
verticality in combo is great so you got
demons coming from above and below you
in some cases but the straight up
platforming stuff is the only thing I
didn't really enjoy the game and got a
little bit too thanks he expand on that
Allah she started end up doing like
sideStrafe jumping and stuff based on
yes actually going to like the rune
challenges I I don't know if you got any
the the time based platforming ones yet
not yet Oh jump maps they're back like
even dance stuff like I totally forgot
that and do one into like red barrel
placement was like in totally amends for
like trying to clear our rooms and
they're everywhere and they're
everywhere in fact the point where you
have to stay the hell away from them
because you'll just get insta kills
liner basically from but that whole
thing about like exploding do you ever
not like you can see the animation your
head when there's like a pinky or an imp
coming towards you and you set off the
thing the red barrel and it explodes and
you see them move slightly to the side I
just burst into blood yeah very good
impression be like it's got that feeling
to it where you like you're just
detonating death all over the place and
it's yeah like I think for a game that
has gone from pillar to post and had
such a long and weird development
history it's so strange that this game
has such a strong identity yeah like it
knows what it it it's so pure it's so
straightforward and it doesn't mask the
fact that you are basically walking from
arena to arena right you enter a room
they say oh there's demons we're gonna
lock it down until you kill them all you
do that you move on and it's just like
you just want the next one to happen
like that's really all it is but the way
that they you know a lot of the maps are
designed are intricate enough and
challenging enough like pack of demons
that really push you to Lin it and
you're constantly scrambling for your
resources like it's that's it's that
tension that anxiety like I
white-knuckled wide-eyed staring my TV
like a tiger for like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you know like again ah yeah the way it
it's not it has such confidence in its
combat to make the combat the star and
it doesn't try yeah it doesn't have
loads of cutscenes and they could have
done a real Wolfenstein I'll I'll of
Wolfenstein but they could have put on a
lot of more campaign and story and
characters but they really that they're
not afraid just to make it about the
combat you know and that the glory kills
in the chainsaw or the cherry on top
because the way that changes the
gameplay and turns it into a beautiful
rhythmic thing where where those things
you know the executions and the chain
stores which i think when we all saw
that demo back at e3 yeah the glory
kills it's like art that's hope that
just feels like it slows it all down I
haven't seen a game mechanic he have
such a like 180 reaction in my life
where's like it looked like oh god
they're putting contextual kills in
Dhoom 2 oh this is actually dislike
solved the medi-pack hunt problem that
would not work in 2016 but a place so
well like beyond just trying to get that
health right like so I'm facing down an
enemy I'm losing health mmm I have like
no ammo I'm loading everything I haven't
in like please stagger please stagger
please stagger they stagger and I sprint
into tear them open and I'm like I'm
back it's just like let's go I chase'll
is the same thing right yes super
limited on fuel yeah and you'll save
that fuel until you see a big enemy is
gonna take a lot of your fuel drag down
on the insta kill but you know it's
gonna top up all your ammo yeah so like
that there's all this undermining
underlying strategy going on in your
brain yeah which didn't exist before the
chainsaw was just a fun weapon to slice
be open with right it's like a joke
almost yeah so all of those things
they've made actually meaningful and
part of what you're doing again it sort
of you know making it all about the
combat you know and that it takes it
back to that feel like you're alone
you're you know there there's little
bits of story elements there if you want
to find them and they're you know there
are also some additional secret stuff
which unlocks you know like a and
appendices kind of thing yeah but I
actually quite like I think those are
rid of good stuff in there right well I
mean you don't need to look no right
your way it tells its story though is
really like quite well the fact you
break out of like a stone sarcophagus
yeah and then like your bloody do
marmaris pentagram on the
I'm like the hell talks about you as the
dude the doom Slayer like yeah it's like
the idea of like deifying this
ridiculous character who didn't really
even her name in the original games yeah
um let's talk about I guess some of the
other maybe shortcomings it might have
like have you dabbled with some of the
other modes actually like multiplayer
stuffs not my phone yeah before we get
to that I mean I will say like the
campaign delivers so many great things
but it does lack a lot of variety you're
right um there cuz you know its doom you
go to hell sorry I but yeah you got a
hell and you go to Mars and you go back
and forth to hell de Mars to held up our
cell to Mars and that gets pretty rope
right that bothered me but the game does
find its footing again later on in the
campaign so that was fine they resolved
itself the multiplayer stuff is is very
very basic it captures sort of part of
the combat that makes dune so special
but it doesn't give you the the odds the
sort of like the crushing looming odds
then your face when you enter an arena
in the campaign I feel like I'm playing
halo right yeah just with a little bit
of satanic dressing yeah time yeah it
feels like a game you've played already
yeah like it's fine yeah but it's it's
it's not the sort of thing where I'm
gonna talk about it with anyone I'm not
gonna bring that up that's not a topic
of discussion and what about the snap my
up stuff uh actually so I think that's
pretty cool the tutorials are pretty
straightforward they teach you how to do
everything within a matter of minutes I
was able to just move stuff around and
place it take it out put it back in undo
things there's a lot of room there to be
creative they let you do things like you
know Taylor the text that appears on
screen in different parts of the
environment and different parts of
omission you can use logic and
interesting ways to have different
objects activate things and some of the
stuff at the communities don't is is
pretty good for a game that's only been
out a handful of days it seems to me the
thing that the community will really run
with down the road and for a game that
has at its core the ability to deliver
something that the campaign does I'm
hoping the community can also build upon
that Yeah right I mean talk about mods
like doom can have those within the game
and I cannot wait to see you already saw
some pretty dumb stuff when you like
that yeah there's the big piano
yeah there's like a big there's like a
music room there was a light moment like
a drum sequencer or something yeah that
was yeah I had a cowbell in the corner I
mean you can every detail how much that
stuff's been made by in ahead of time
you're right i guess but uh yeah you'd
hope so i'm like i imagine i'm not sure
if i asked marty this when he was in two
weeks ago but i imagine you could do
some sort of cross-platform so because
snap map is just a tool right so if
somebody made something on playstation 4
what I stopped in Jersey they talk about
that you see 3 can you can you do to
cross platform however maybe I'm mixing
it up with basically one snapchat I mean
when you login to snapchat it does close
the game and reboot into snapchat yeah
just for multiplayer just stabbed man
snapping oh yeah it's not jack yeah
they've included snapchat I didn't do
here's a here's the funky town level I
play as well they're funky town is
playing on this disco so yeah great
that's gonna be that's the right level
it's the right level of dumb yeah right
there and yeah it's I guess well you
know Peters point is totally right we'll
see it's bit lives or dies on what the
community does right so we'll have to
wait and see we called hopefully if it's
cross-platform than the pool of
creations then is shared that will be
you know hopefully everyone gets to
enjoy the spoils of the the good stuff
that's made ya do whens review up later
today cool I mean yeah we're literally
just polishing it alright it's really
not your site here just lighting the
last candle and placing the last bloody
skulls than the review alright so yeah
check back on gamespot com to see Peters
review for do
you